[Music]  my father lusted after freedom  the kind of freedom most free people  never experienced  the suspect has been identified as john  vogel the second largest counterfeiter  in us history  vocal printed over 22 million dollars  he came and went from our lives he  always made me feel like part of a  bigger world  just take good care of her babies okay  [Music]  dad what do you do  [Music]  just tell me the truth you're gonna get  it when you  walk a mile in my shoes i'm guilty to  improve an innocence  [Music]  through the years long and wearing  with you my dreams i will be sharing  in whatever you choose to endeavor  i will support you forever  i think the greatest hope a man can have  is leave something beautiful behind  so maybe  hands up who had a great summer  [Music]  you